so I'm holding the phone in my hand you
know over a dozen while delivering
all and this is the Tweet okay um got
pull up the tweet I didn't have it ready
okay so I'm still not paying attention
to the content at all I'm not interested
in the content the other question I get
is uh this is a real question that that
comes up a lot it's a fair question
which is like why well how is this ever
a thing why did anyone ever think that
this was a good idea for you to do a
show in the car the answer to that is
that when I first started the daily wire
um before I even had a podcast they
wanted me to uh to record like little
video rant just because they need they
needed content and I was mostly writing
and they said you need to make more
content than that we've got to squeeze
every bit of content we can out of here
and so they wanted me to start doing
these a little every once a while just
like do a little video and uh and post
it there wasn't a lot of Direction